nos équipes continueront à travailler
dur la semaine prochaine nous resterons
en contact étroit dans les prochains
jours d'importantes divergences
subsistent dans un certain nombre de
dossiers y compris la pêche et le
soi-disant cadre non faussée de
concurrence les deux dirigeants ont
accepté de rester personnellement en
contact et se sont entendus pour que les
équipes de négociateurs continuent leurs
pourparlers la semaine prochaine à
londres
à compter de lundi et voyez à présent
l'analyse de gilbert cazassus sur les
différents scénarios il est professeur
en études européennes
les deux scénarios sont totalement
envisage cia ont dit le grand perdant
serait l'amant bretagne c'est clair et
net
mais c'est pas aussi dans l' avantage de
certains pays européens notamment des
pays exportateurs je pense notamment aux
pays du nord de l'europe
il faut jamais l'oublier extrêmement
important aussi lu tunnel sous la manche
quid aussi des contrôles des camions
quitter export trop important des
produits entre la bretagne et l'union
européenne et la france s'est très
comment dirais-je susceptible sur le
marché concernant la pêche car c'est
aussi la question de la survie de
quelques embarcations de pêcheurs du
nord ouest de la france donc là il ya un
intérêt national
mais il ya aussi plus globalement des
intérêts européens et c'est le lieu des
bacs faut-il privilégier les intérêts
nationaux les intérêts européens
je pense qu'en l'occurrence il faudrait
même en mieux privilégier les intérêts
européens car il est important pour
l'union européenne de ne pas du tout
céder à des propositions démagogiques de
mort une zone
la situation sanitaire en france à
présent est selon le ministre de la
santé il y aurait une forme de
ralentissement dans la progression de
l'épidémie
mais olivier viron ne fait aucun
pronostic à ce stade alors que le cas
vous le voyez des quarante mille morts a
été franchi depuis le début de
l'épidémie il y a trois cent six
nouveaux décès ces dernières 24 heures
et plus de 4000 patients en réanimation
le ministère de la santé qui
il a promis de doubler le nombre de lits
en réanimation dixième jour de
confinement en tout cas pour les
français et vous le voyez sur ces images
de charles beaudry ce dimanche des
parisiens qui ont passé des moments de
détente en famille entre amis dans les
parcs qui reste ouvert c'était le cas
notamment au parc montsouris dans le 14e
arrondissement
des images qui ont fait réagir notre
invité éric tricot infirmier
anesthésiste à l'hôpital chu
henri-mondor à créteil et membre de sud
santé fait réagir parce que on est sur
des chiffres il ya 24 ou 48 heures on
avait un nombre de décès qui était quand
même assez conséquent il est passé la
barre des 800 qui correspondait aux
premiers chiffres que l'on avait lors de
la première vague avec un compliment qui
était générale et qui était totale là on
est sur un confinement
je crois qu'on peut même pas appeler ça
de confinement je dis pas qu'il faut
être utilisé les citoyens français mais
le citoyen français si on me dit la
vérité et si on me dit les choses
clairement il va se prendre en main et
il va être se discipliner là on est dans
le petit peu dans le grand n'importe
quoi
ce qui était à l'origine de la première
gbagbo si vous en avez des communicants
de ce gouvernement qui vous disaient que
la le bas ce qui n'était pas adapté
qu'il faut ne pas le mettre dans la rue
il fallait pas le mettre en société il
fallait pas le mettre devant tout le
monde il fallait laisser ça aux
professionnels voilà c'est c'est eh on
était dans le grand n'importe quoi
et là on a l'impression qu'on ne se sert
pas d idée de ce qui s'est passé dans
lors de la première vague et on
recommence voilà sauf que les deux
clusters principaux liés à la première
vague était l'île de france est la
france
est ce là tous les clusters fleurissent
de partout ça flambe de partout sur le
territoire national donc il faut il faut
que les citoyens prennent comprennent
que nous n'aurons pas le renfort ni
médical et paramédical donc ils nous
doivent nous faire preuve d'une
solidarité envers les personnels
soignants
il n'y va plus de nous applaudir à 20
heures il n'y va plus parce que
malheureusement ils sont pas mulhouse
accompagné corinne il a fallu porter
haut et fort nos revendications en juin
là maintenant il faut jouer le jeu
on rentre de plain pied dans la dans
l'hiver on sait pas ce que ça va donner
en sortie d'hiver
il faut qu'on soit beaucoup plus
discipliné et après dix jours de
fermeture forcée quatre associations de
magasins de proximité et de centres
commerciaux appelle le gouvernement à
interdire la vente en ligne de produits
non essentiels dans une tribune publiée
dans le journal du dimanche
elle demande la réouverture dès le 12
novembre de leur commerce jugés non
essentiels parler par l'exécutif il
dénonce je cite une scandaleuse et
inégalités face à notamment en géant du
web regarder les dispositions prises
pour juguler la propagation du virus ne
font qu'accroître la scandaleuse
inégalité de traitement pré existante
entre les commerçants physique et les
marchands du web au péril des premiers
et au profit exclusif des second et
parmi les signataires de cette tribune
président de la confédération des
commerçants de france francis palombes i
qui dit craindre de nombreuses faillites
écoutez le nous demandons bien sûr la
première chose que nous souhaitons que
nous demandons parce que nous ne sommes
pas en plus les plus dangereux avec nos
marchés ouverts et bien c'est réouvrir à
partir du 12 novembre dans le meilleur
des cas et avant le début décembre pour
que les fêtes de noël pour le commerce
physique ne soit pas complètement ruiné
anéantis au risque de faillites futures
c'est très très grave si nous nous
sommes réunis mobiliser associés pour
dire non à l'hégémonie non à l'injustice
dans les formes de distribution
et bien c'est parce que nous voulons
sauver notre commerce
nous voulons et nous voulons bien sûr
qu'une convention de genève pour capa
soit dictée par le gouvernement pour
interdire de black friday interdire
toute promotion avant la fin de l'année
c'est scandaleux qu amazon 10 à ses
clients un blake frye des fantastiques
avec des produits d'extrême orient les
autres avec des prix fenomeno pendant le
black friday dire aux consommateurs par
rapport au marché du jouet et bien
acheté quatre fois en quatre fois sans
frais vous jouez pour la noël
véritablement une provocation et puis
sachez que le parlement a adopté hier
soir la prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire il permettra au gouvernement
de prendre des mesures par ordonnance
jusqu'au 16 février prochain un passage
en force dénoncée par la gauche qui a
décidé de saisir le conseil
constitutionnel
l'actualité internationale en bref et en
images à présent avec ses nouvelles
manifestations anti macron au pakistan
avec de nouveaux des drapeaux français
et des portraits du président piétiner
et brûlé 1 karachi les protestataires
ont réclamé l'expulsion de l'ambassadeur
français et appelé au boycott des
produits français
manifestation à l'initiative d'un parti
islamiste après le droit au blasphème
défendue par emmanuel macron le
blasphème est passible de la peine de
mort au pakistan
un nouveau dimanche de rassemblements en
biélorussie pour exiger la démission du
président loukachenko depuis sa
réélection il ya trois mois ils sont des
milliers à se réunir chaque semaine dans
les rues de la capitale pour l'opposante
svetlana tikhonov sky a exilé en
lituanie le président biélorusse je cite
a perdu sa légitimité et son pouvoir
elle dit espérer bientôt rencontrer joe
biden et puis en thaïlande des milliers
de manifestants auprès du grand palais
de bangkok ils ont symboliquement déposé
des lettres de revendication à
l'intention du roi
il espère ainsi entamer un dialogue sur
une réforme de la monarchie ils
réclament également la démission du
premier ministre au pouvoir depuis le
coup d'état de 2014 est confirmé à son
poste par des élections controversées
l'an dernier
ces tensions à présent en côte d'ivoire
plus d'une semaine après l'élection
présidentielle qui avait été boycotté
par l'opposition et sachez que pascal
affi n'guessan a été arrêté dans la nuit
de vendredi à samedi
c'est le président du front populaire
ivoirien qui avait annoncé la formation
d'un gouvernement parallèle dans la
foulée de la réélection à un troisième
mandat d'alassane ouattara un scrutin
que les opposants ne reconnaissent
toujours par une douzaine de leaders de
ces protestations sont poursuivis pour
complot contre l'autorité de l'état
top1 air de déjà vu plein sur la crise
post électorale en côte d'ivoire en 2010
l'issue du second tour de la
présidentielle entre laurent gbagbo et
alassane ouattara provoque d'importantes
violences dans le pays notamment
interethniques
si les affrontements après la
proclamation de la troisième victoire
d'alassane ouattara ont provoqué au
moins 40 décès la crise électorale de
2010 2011 avait paralysé le pays pendant
des mois et causé la mort de plus de
3000 personnes
autre différence si l'opposition emmenée
par alassane ouattara disposez d'un fort
soutien populaire en 2010 notamment dans
le nord du pays
c'est beaucoup moins le cas aujourd'hui
les figures de l'opposition ont du mal à
faire front uni malgré la création du
conseil national de transition
l'ex président laurent gbagbo s'est par
exemple montré défavorable à la
participation de son parti au cnt par
ailleurs le chef de l'exécutif ivoirien
a décidé d'adopter une attitude de
fermeté envers ses opposants
considérant l'initiative du conseil
national de transition comme
éditions ainsi le domicile de l'ex
président et figure de l'opposition
henri konan bédié est entouré par les
forces de sécurité d'autres figures de
l'opposition comme pascal affi n'guessan
ont d'ores et déjà été arrêté des
décisions qui entache la crédibilité
d'alassane ouattara auprès de la
communauté internationale
enfin le toujours populaire ex président
ivoirien pourrait être l'acteur
principal d'une éventuelle sortie de
crise l'homme de 75 ans devrait
rapidement faire son retour dans le pays
avec l'accord de la présidence après le
non lieu prononcé par la cour pénale
internationale
un accord avec son vieil ennemi alassane
ouattara pourrait apaiser les tensions
reste à savoir les ambitions de l'ex
homme fort de la côte d'ivoire et c'est
la fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité on se retrouve dans 30 minutes
restez avec nous
[Musique]
chacun pour soi dieu pour tous de cecco
politique n'a jamais été obligé de dire
la veille d idée courageuse des mots qui
comptent la haine en soi vient de
grignan aujourd'hui une gauche
extrêmement tous les témoins de notre
époque sont dans la grande interview
[Musique]
nous parle de l'afrique comme d'un
continent en perpétuelle de vie son
dysfonctionnement actuel tient à
l'absence de redistribution à la
population par des dirigeants qui ont
une fâcheuse tendance à tout garder pau
et pays occidentaux ont favorisé cette
dérive en encourageant le maintien au
pouvoir de politiciens de plus en plus
âgés pour assurer la stabilité des pays
et des sous régions elles ont eu la
prétention de croire que les valeurs
qu'elle défend des est imposé par la
force dans leur conquête était universel
dans cette terre des possibles
s'esquisse les figures du monde à venir
il faut changer notre logiciel et
arrêtez de dénigrer le faire à
l'africaine en octroyant au management à
l'anglo-saxonne
[Musique]
dans les banques où la diversité c'est
un autre point fort pas notre point
faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs un
certain chouhada et tout le monde
discute est finalement que mon discuter
ils sont trouvés entre le même drapeau
libanais pour une fois vous voyez des
images assez touchants de l'armée qui
était presque impliqué avec les
manifestants aujourd'hui on sent que le
ton a changé c'est la cause des hommes
politiques et sont en train de manipuler
l'armée on sait très bien pourquoi ils
nous tirent dessus c'est pas s'ils
savent que c'est leur fin ils se
préparent le seul langage qu'ils
connaissaient la violence ne va pas très
violent mais on va rester
[Musique]